[Musique]
jalice au lieu du jardin que
voici c'était la zone et tous ceux qui
s'eni des masures des to un
solite des ruines paromèent pour un sous
quant à la faunne habitant là-dessous
c'était la fine fleur C t
leslite la fine fleur l'élite du pavé
des besogneux des guux des
réprouvés des mendiant
rivalisant de
[Musique]
tar deses chevaux de retour des propres
rien ainsi qu'un crooc note un musicien
une va accrocher à sa
[Musique]
guitare adopté par ce beau monde à
tendri une petite fée avait
fleue au milieu de toute cette
bassesse comme on l'avait trouvé près du
ruissau abandonné en un berceau à tout
hasard on l'a peu les
[Musique]
princesses or un soir dieu du ciel
protégez-nous la voilà qui monte sur les
genoux de coqun et doucement
soupire en rougissant quand même un
petit peu c'est toi que j'aime et si tu
veux tu peux m'embrasser sur la bouche
et même
P tout beau princesse arrête un peu ton
tire j'ai pas tellement l'étofes du
satire tu as 13 ans j'en ai 30 qui
sonne grosse différence et je ne suis
pas chaud pour tâer la paille humide du
cacha mais croque notes dirait rien à
[Musique]
personne un insiste pas fitil d'un ton
railleur d'abord tu n'es pas mon genre
et d'ailleurs mon cœur est déjà pris par
une
grande alors princesse est parti en
courant alors princesse est parti en
pleurant chagrine qu'on est boudé son
[Musique]
offrande il y a pas eu
détournement de mineur le croqueene au
matin de bonheur à l'anglaise affilé
dans la charrette
des chifonniers en grattant sa
guitare passant par là quelques 20 ans
plus tard il a le sentiment qu'il le
[Musique]
regret